- ברוכים הבאים להבנת
מידע קוונטי וחישוב.
שמי John Watrous, ואני המנהל הטכני
של IBM Quantum Education.
המטרה של הסדרה הזו היא לתת לכם
הבנה מוצקה של מידע קוונטי וחישוב, וזה אומר להיכנס
לפרטים הטכניים
של מידע קוונטי ולראות איך מחשוב
קוונטי באמת עובד, מה הוא יכול לעשות ומה הוא לא יכול.
אם עדיין לא
צפיתם בסרטון הסקירה של הסדרה, אני ממליץ לכם לבדוק אותו.
בסרטון הזה, תמצאו מידע על איזה רקע
מוקדם מומלץ לסדרה הזו, וגם סקירה של
הנושאים שיכוסו.
בנוסף, הקפידו לבדוק
את ספר הלימוד של Qiskit, שמכסה את אותו
חומר כמו סדרת הסרטונים הזו בצורה כתובה,
והוא גם כולל
רכיבים אינטראקטיביים וממשקים לחומרה ותוכנה שנועדו לעזור לכם להבין טוב יותר
מידע קוונטי וחישוב. תמצאו קישורים לסרטון הסקירה ולספר הלימוד של Qiskit
בתיאור.
זה שיעור אחד של
יחידה אחת בסדרה.
יחידה אחת מכסה את היסודות
של מידע קוונטי, ובשיעור הראשון של היחידה הזו, נתמקד באיך
מידע קוונטי עובד
עבור מערכות בודדות, כלומר שיש לנו
רק מערכת פיזיקלית אחת או מכשיר מסוג כלשהו ש
מאחסן מידע קוונטי
ואנחנו מתייחסים לאיך
המערכת או המכשיר הזה עובדים בבידוד.
בשיעור שאחרי זה, נדון באיך
מידע קוונטי עובד כשיש לנו מערכות מרובות וזה יאפשר לנו
לתאר מושגים
מעניינים וחשובים כמו אלגוריתמים קוונטיים שמשתמשים במספר qubits
ופרוטוקולים קוונטיים
שמערבים מספר אנשים שמעבדים מידע קוונטי ומשדרים אותו הלוך
ושוב אחד לשני.
אבל לפני שנכנס לדיונים האלה, הגיוני להתחיל עם
ההגדרה הפשוטה יחסית של מערכת בודדת בבידוד,
בחלקו כי טוב להתחיל פשוט, אבל גם כי כפי שנראה, התיאור של איך
מידע קוונטי עובד
עבור מערכות בודדות בבידוד מוביל בצורה טבעית והגיונית מאוד לתיאור של איך
עבור מערכות מרובות.
הנה סקירה קצרה של השיעור.
אנחנו נתחיל בלדבר על
מידע קלאסי.
המטרה של השיעור הזה היא לא להסביר איך
מידע קלאסי עובד, אלא להסביר איך
מידע קוונטי עובד,
אבל כדי להסביר איך
מידע קוונטי עובד, מאוד עוזר להתחיל
עם מידע קלאסי ולהשתמש בו כ
נקודת התייחסות מוכרת
כשאנחנו דנים במידע קוונטי.
ברמה מתמטית, למידע קוונטי וקלאסי יש תיאורים די דומים עם כמה הבדלים מהותיים, כמובן.
למעשה, מידע קוונטי
לא באמת נפרד ממידע קלאסי בכלל.
הוא הרחבה של
מידע קלאסי.
העובדה היא,
לפחות לדעתי, שאי אפשר באמת
להבין מידע קוונטי אם לא מבינים
מידע קלאסי,
אז להתחיל עם מידע
קלאסי הגיוני.
אני כן מצפה שהתוכן
הזה יהיה מוכר לחלק מהצופים, אבל גם אם זה מוכר לכם, אני לא ממליץ לדלג על זה.
בנוסף להדגשת ההיבטים של מידע קלאסי שהכי רלוונטיים ל
הבנת מידע קוונטי, אנחנו נציג את
סימון Dirac בחלק הזה,
שזו דרך סטנדרטית
שאנחנו נשתמש בה כדי לתאר וקטורים ו
מטריצות לאורך כל הסדרה.
כפי שמתברר, סימון Dirac לא
ספציפי למידע קוונטי.
אפשר להשתמש בו באותה מידה בהקשר של מידע קלאסי וגם בהרבה הגדרות אחרות שבהן וקטורים ומטריצות מופיעים.
אז נעבור למידע קוונטי, ובפרט, נדון
בייצוג של מצבים קוונטיים כוקטורים,
סוג פשוט של מדידה שנקרא מדידת בסיס סטנדרטי, ופעולות אוניטריות, שמתארות שינויים בזמן
בדיד במערכות קוונטיות.
שוב, הכל בהגדרה
של מערכות בודדות.
לפני שנתחיל בשיעור עצמו, יהיה מועיל להבהיר שיש בעצם שני תיאורים
של מידע קוונטי, התיאור המפושט, שבו נתמקד
בשיעור הזה
ולאורך כל היחידה הראשונה והתיאור הכללי, שמכוסה ביחידה מאוחרת יותר, ספציפית ב
יחידה השלישית של הסדרה.
התיאור המפושט,
נאמן לשמו, הוא פשוט יותר ובדרך כלל
לומדים אותו קודם.
בתיאור המפושט, כפי שכבר רמזתי, מצבים קוונטיים מיוצגים על ידי וקטורים ופעולות מיוצגות
על ידי מטריצות אוניטריות.
התיאור הזה של מידע
קוונטי מספיק להבנת
רוב האלגוריתמים הקוונטיים, למשל,
אז הוא לא מפושט מדי, הוא הדבר האמיתי.
עם זאת, כפי ש
נגלה תוך כדי, יש לו כמה מגבלות.
למשל, אם אנחנו רוצים
למדל את ההשפעות של רעש על מערכות קוונטיות, התיאור הזה מתגלה כחסר.
התיאור הכללי, מצד
שני, הוא יותר כללי ובסופו של דבר, הוא יותר
חזק במובן המתמטי.
בתיאור הזה, מצבים קוונטיים מיוצגים על ידי סוג מיוחד של מטריצות
שנקראות מטריצות צפיפות,
וסוג יותר כללי של
מדידות ופעולות אפשר לתאר כולל
רעש, למשל.
הוא עקבי לחלוטין עם
התיאור המפושט ולמעשה, אפשר בעיקרון לראות
את התיאור המפושט
כמקרה פרטי של
התיאור הכללי, והוא גם כולל מידע קלאסי כמקרה פרטי.
הוא גם ממש
יפה באיך שהכל עובד, אז אני ממליץ בחום ללמוד על התיאור הכללי הזה
כשהזמן מתאים, אבל התיאור המפושט הוא המקום הטבעי יותר להתחיל, ולכן ככה נעשה.
אנחנו נתחיל בלדבר על מידע קלאסי עם עין על ההיבטים
של מידע קלאסי שהכי רלוונטיים
למידע קוונטי
ולדרך שבה הוא
מתואר מתמטית.
דמיינו שיש לנו
מערכת פיזיקלית או מכשיר מסוג כלשהו שמאחסן מידע.
אנחנו ניתן למערכת הזו את השם X, אבל אין שום דבר
חשוב בשם הזה.
אנחנו יכולים להשתמש בכל
שם אחר אם נעדיף, אבל רק כדי לבחור שם,
נקרא למערכת X.
אנחנו נניח הנחה לגבי X, שהיא שיש
קבוצה סופית של מצבים קלאסיים שבהם X יכול להיות
ברגע נתון כלשהו.
כאן, כשאני מתייחס למצב קלאסי, אני מתכוון לתצורה של המערכת שאפשר לזהות ול
תאר באופן חד-משמעי
בלי שום אי-ודאות או שגיאה.
באמת, זה משהו שאפשר לחשוב עליו באופן אינטואיטיבי. ברמה מתמטית, אנחנו פשוט מגדירים את
קבוצת המצבים הקלאסיים,
אנחנו בוחרים אותה איך שאנחנו רוצים או בכל דרך שהכי טוב
מתארת את המכשיר שאנחנו עובדים איתו.
בואו ניתן את השם סיגמא ל
קבוצה הזו של מצבים קלאסיים, ושוב, תנו לי להדגיש
שאנחנו מניחים שסיגמא היא קבוצה סופית.
קבוצת המצבים הקלאסיים
של המערכת הזו X היא לא גדולה באופן אינסופי כמו
קבוצת כל המספרים הטבעיים.
היא סופית, וזו פשוט
הנחה שאנחנו עושים.
למשל, יכול להיות ש-X הוא ביט, ובמקרה הזה, קבוצת המצבים הקלאסיים היא קבוצה שמכילה שני
אלמנטים: אפס ואחד.
לפעמים אנחנו מתייחסים לקבוצה
הזו כאלפבית הבינארי.
דוגמה נוספת היא ש-X הוא
קובייה רגילה בעלת שש פאות, ובמקרה הזה, המצבים הקלאסיים הם המספרים אחד עד שש.
כמובן, אנחנו מדברים
על הפשטה כאן.
לקובייה בעלת שש פאות אמיתית
יכולים להיות הרבה מאפיינים שונים כמו המיקום המדויק שלה,
הכיוון שלה,
הטמפרטורה שלה, וכן הלאה. אבל ביחס למידע שבדרך כלל הכי רלוונטי כשאנחנו מדברים על קובייה בעלת שש פאות,
המצבים הקלאסיים הם
המספרים אחד עד שש שמצוינים על ידי מספר הנקודות על הפאה שפונה למעלה.
אם X הוא מתג על
מאוורר חשמלי רגיל שיכול להיות לכם בבית, אז אולי המצבים הקלאסיים
הם ההגדרות חזק,
בינוני, חלש וכבוי.
אלה רק דוגמאות. אנחנו יכולים לדמיין מערכות עם קבוצות מצבים קלאסיים
שונות מאלה, אבל אני מקווה שהן מעבירות את הרעיון
שהמושג הזה של מצב קלאסי הוא משהו שצריך להיות
מוכר ואפשר להבין אותו במונחים פשוטים ואינטואיטיביים.
מבחינה מתמטית, קבוצת המצבים הקלאסיים
היא פשוט קבוצה סופית, וכמובן, הקבוצה הזו חייבת להיות
גם לא ריקה.
חייב להיות לפחות
מצב קלאסי אחד שהמערכת יכולה להיות בו וחייבים להיות לפחות
שני מצבים קלאסיים
אם המערכת הולכת להיות שימושית בכלל לאחסון מידע.
עכשיו, במצבים מסוימים, אנחנו יכולים לדעת ש-X נמצא
במצב מסוים, אבל בהרבה מצבים,
שעולים בהקשר
של עיבוד מידע, יכול להיות אי-ודאות לגבי המצב הקלאסי של
מערכת ברגע מסוים
כך שלכל מצב קלאסי אפשרי יש הסתברות מסוימת שמשויכת אליו.
למשל, אם X הוא ביט, אז אולי המצב הוא ש-X נמצא במצב הקלאסי אפס
עם הסתברות שלושה רבעים והוא במצב אחד
עם הסתברות רבע.
אנחנו נתייחס לזה
כמצב הסתברותי, ואנחנו יכולים לבטא
את המצב ההסתברותי הזה, כפי שאתם רואים כאן,
פשוט על ידי ציון מה
ההסתברויות עבור המצבים הקלאסיים השונים.
דרך יותר תמציתית לבטא
את המצב ההסתברותי הזה היא באמצעות וקטור, ספציפית הייצוג
שאתם רואים כאן
הוא וקטור עמודה, והוקטור הזה מציין
מה ההסתברויות עבור שני המצבים הקלאסיים האפשריים.
ליתר דיוק, הרשומה הראשונה מציינת
מה ההסתברות ש-X יהיה במצב אפס, והרשומה השנייה אומרת
לנו מה ההסתברות
שהמערכת תהיה במצב אחד. זו פשוט הדרך הטבעית לסדר את האלפבית הבינארי,
או לפחות, זו הדרך
שלמדנו לעשות את זה. עם אפס קודם ואחד שני.
מעכשיו, נשתמש
במונח וקטור הסתברות כדי לציין וקטור כזה.
ספציפית, זה וקטור שכל הרשומות שלו הן
מספרים ממשיים אי-שליליים ושסכום
הרשומות שווה לאחד,
אז הגיוני לחשוב
על הרשומות האלה כהסתברויות.
כאן בדוגמה הזו, יש רק שתי רשומות כי יש רק שני
מצבים קלאסיים של המערכת שאנחנו מדברים עליה,
אבל באופן כללי, יכול להיות
כל מספר של רשומות עם ההבנה
שיש רשומה אחת לכל מצב קלאסי
של כל מערכת שאנחנו מדברים עליה.
אנחנו נמשיך
לדון במידע קלאסי, וקטורי הסתברות וכן
הלאה בעוד רגע, אבל קודם, זה ממש יעזור
להציג סימון מסוים
לתיאור וקטורים שנקרא סימון Dirac.
למעשה, זה רק החלק הראשון
של סימון Dirac.
יש עוד כמה היבטים
של סימון Dirac שנראה קצת
יותר מאוחר בשיעור.
הסימון הזה הולך להיות
מרכזי מאוד בדרך שבה אנחנו מתארים מידע קוונטי, אז חיוני
להבין איך הוא עובד,
אבל למזלנו, הוא מאוד פשוט והוא באמת לא
קשור ספציפית למידע קוונטי,
אז אנחנו יכולים להציג אותו עכשיו
בהקשר המוכר של מידע קלאסי.
כמו קודם, אנחנו מניחים שיש לנו קבוצה סיגמא של
מצבים קלאסיים של מערכת כלשהי, ובואו נניח
שיש לנו סדר
של המצבים הקלאסיים האלה, בדיוק כמו שהתייחסנו ל
סדר של האלפבית הבינארי
בדוגמה הקודמת. דרך נוספת לומר את זה
היא שהאלמנטים של סיגמא מוצבים בהתאמה
עם המספרים השלמים
מאחד ועד כמה
אלמנטים שנמצאים בסיגמא, שזה מה שהסימון הזה כאן עם שני פסים סביב סיגמא אומר.
זה מספר
האלמנטים בקבוצה סיגמא.
אז יש מצב ראשון,
מצב שני, וכן הלאה.
הסדר הספציפי או
ההתאמה שאנחנו בוחרים לא באמת ישנו כל כך הרבה.
מה שבאמת חשוב הוא
שיש לנו סדר ואנחנו נשארים עם אותו סדר.
עבור הרבה קבוצות מצבים
קלאסיים שנפגוש, יהיה סדר סטנדרטי בדיוק כמו שיש לנו עם
האלפבית הבינארי,
ואם אין סדר סטנדרטי, אנחנו פשוט יכולים לבחור אחד.
אבל מה שלא יהיה, ההבנה היא שאנחנו נשארים איתו.
עכשיו, הנה הסימון
שמוצג.
עבור כל בחירה של מצב
קלאסי a מהקבוצה סיגמא שלנו, אנחנו כותבים את זה כאן, שנקרא ket a
כדי להתכוון לוקטור העמודה
שיש בו אחד ברשומה שמתאימה ל-a ואפס לכל שאר הרשומות.
למשל, אם נחזור
לאלפבית הבינארי, שכפי שאולי ניחשתם, הוא דוגמה מאוד חשובה
שנחזור אליה שוב ושוב. אז ket אפס ו-ket אחד הם הוקטורים שמוגדרים כאן.
Ket אפס הוא הוקטור
שיש בו אחד ברשומה שמתאימה למצב הקלאסי אפס, שזו הרשומה הראשונה,
ואפס לכל שאר הרשומות, ובמקרה הזה, יש
רק רשומה אחת נוספת.
באופן דומה, ket אחד הוא
הוקטור הזה כאן שבו יש אחד ב
רשומה שמתאימה לאחד,
שזו הרשומה השנייה, ואפס לכל שאר הרשומות, שזו, שוב, רק רשומה אחת.
הנה דוגמה נוספת. בדוגמה הזו, יש לנו
קבוצת מצבים קלאסיים סיגמא שמתאימה לארבעת הסמלים
בחפיסת קלפים סטנדרטית: תלתן, יהלום, לב ועלה.
במקרה הזה, אין באמת
סדר מוסכם עליו של הסמלים האלה.
בהרבה משחקי קלפים, אין סדר בכלל. הם פשוט ארבעה סמלים שונים וזה כל מה שחשוב, ויש משחקי קלפים
שונים שכן מסדרים את הסמלים האלה
בדרכים שונות, אבל זה לא באמת משנה.
אנחנו יכולים פשוט לבחור
סדר כמו זה שאתם רואים כאן.
במקרה הזה זה סדר אלפביתי לפי שמות ארבעת הסמלים באנגלית,
בהנחה שבחרנו
את הסדר הספציפי הזה, אנחנו מגדירים ארבעה וקטורים: ket תלתן, ket יהלום,
ket לב, ו-ket עלה
כפי שאתם רואים כאן, והוקטורים האלה מתאימים
לתיאור הכללי שאתם רואים כאן למעלה.
בהינתן שבחרנו
את הסדר הספציפי הזה לארבעת הסמלים.
אנחנו יכולים לעשות את אותו הדבר לכל קבוצת מצבים
קלאסיים שנבחר.
תוך זכירה שקבוצת מצבים
קלאסיים תמיד אומרת קבוצה סופית ולא ריקה.
וקטורים מהצורה הזו
נקראים וקטורי בסיס סטנדרטי, וזו עובדה מאוד בסיסית על וקטורים שכל וקטור אפשר
לבטא בדרך ייחודית
כצירוף ליניארי
של וקטורי בסיס סטנדרטי.
למשל, אם נחזור לדוגמה מלפני רגע, את וקטור ההסתברות
שראינו אפשר לבטא
כפי שאתם רואים כאן. זו בעצם רק דרך חלופית לבטא וקטורים
שתהיה מאוד שימושית מכמה סיבות בהמשך.
ועם הסימון הזה עכשיו בידיים שלנו, בואו נחזור לדיון
על מידע קלאסי ומצבים הסתברותיים, בפרט.
ובואו נבחן מה קורה
כשאנחנו מודדים מערכת בזמן שהיא במצב הסתברותי כלשהו.
אנחנו לא בהכרח
מתייחסים למדידה או לפעולת מדידה
של משהו בהקשר קלאסי, אבל המונח הגיוני.
בעיקרו של דבר, כשאנחנו מדברים
על מדידת המערכת X בהקשר הזה, אנחנו פשוט מתכוונים שאנחנו מסתכלים עליה ומזהים את המצב שהיא נמצאת בו.
כמובן, כשאנחנו מסתכלים על המערכת, אנחנו לא רואים מצב הסתברותי, אנחנו רואים מצב קלאסי,
והמצב הקלאסי
הספציפי שאנחנו רואים הוא כזה שאפשר
לדמיין שנבחר באקראי לפי ההסתברויות.
עכשיו, אתם יכולים להתנגד
מבחינה פילוסופית לרעיון שהמצב הקלאסי שאנחנו רואים נבחר בצורה אקראית כלשהי
ברגע שאנחנו מודדים או מסתכלים על המערכת, המערכת פשוט הייתה במצב
קלאסי מסוים כל הזמן
ופשוט קרה שלמדנו
מה המצב היה, אבל לצורך החשיבה על המסגרת המתמטית
שאנחנו עובדים בה,
זה בסדר לחשוב על זה ככה ולעשות את זה יאפשר לנו למתוח מקבילה עם
מידע קוונטי קצת יותר מאוחר.
בואו נניח שהמצב
הקלאסי שאנחנו רואים הוא המצב הקלאסי a, שיכול להיות כל מצב בקבוצה סיגמא שלנו.
זה משנה את המצב ההסתברותי
של X באופן כללי, לפחות מנקודת המבט שלנו.
להסתברויות כבר אין
משמעות כי עכשיו אנחנו יודעים מה
המצב הקלאסי של X.
הוא a, וכבר אין
אי-ודאות לגבי זה.
אז עכשיו נגיד את זה
שההסתברות שהמערכת נמצאת במצב a היא אחד.
אנחנו יודעים את זה כי הרגע הסתכלנו על זה וראינו שהמצב הקלאסי הוא a, אז המצב ההסתברותי החדש של X הוא כזה
שבו ההסתברות
להיות במצב הקלאסי a שווה לאחד.
והמצב ההסתברותי הזה מיוצג על ידי
וקטור ההסתברות ket a.
יש לנו אחד ברשומה שמתאימה למצב הקלאסי a ואפס בכל שאר הרשומות.
למשל, אם שוב
נבחן את המצב שבו X הוא ביט ויש לנו את אותו
מצב הסתברותי כמו קודם,
אז אם נמדוד את X, אנחנו יכולים לדמיין שמתרחש
מעבר.
עם הסתברות שלושה רבעים, אנחנו רואים את המצב הקלאסי אפס, ועל ידי המדידה, אנחנו עוברים ל-ket אפס
כמצב ההסתברותי שלנו,
ועם הסתברות רבע, אנחנו עוברים ל-ket אחד.
אפשר לחשוב על זה כמעבר של ידע אם אתם מעדיפים, בניגוד למעבר
פיזי ממשי,
אבל מה שחשוב
לצורך השיעור הזה הוא לזהות איך המתמטיקה עובדת.
זה סוג של טריוויאלי למעשה, אבל על ידי זיהוי הטריוויאליות הזו, התיאור האנלוגי
עבור ההגדרה הקוונטית
אולי ייראה קצת פחות מסתורי.
הערה אחרונה היא שלאדם אחר שלא קרה שראה מה
המצב הקלאסי של X היה כשמדדנו אותו,
המצב ההסתברותי
באופן טבעי לא ישתנה כתוצאה מכך שמדדנו.
זה בסדר. אנשים שונים יכולים
להיות בעלי ידע שונה על מערכת מסוימת ובהתאם לכך לבחור
מצבים הסתברותיים שונים
כדי לייצג את
הידע שלהם על המערכת הזו.
בחלק האחרון של הדיון הזה על מידע קלאסי, נדבר על פעולות קלאסיות שאפשר לבצע על מערכת,
ונתחיל עם פעולות דטרמיניסטיות.
כשאנחנו מבצעים פעולה על מערכת, המצב שלה בדרך כלל משתנה כתוצאה מכך, ובהקשר הזה, המילה דטרמיניסטי אומרת
שהתוצאה של ביצוע
הפעולה תלויה לחלוטין בכל מצב קלאסי
שהמערכת הייתה בו
לפני שהפעולה בוצעה.
במילים אחרות, אין
אלמנט של מזל כשפעולה דטרמיניסטית
מבוצעת, אז אין אקראיות
או אי-ודאות מעורבות.
במונחים מתמטיים, פעולות דטרמיניסטיות
מתוארות על ידי פונקציות.
כל פונקציה f מהצורה
שאתם רואים כאן, שאומרת ששני הקלט והפלט של הפונקציה
מתאימים לאלמנטים של
קבוצת המצבים הקלאסיים שלנו סיגמא מתארת פעולה דטרמיניסטית.
המצב הקלאסי a
הופך למצב f של a עבור כל בחירה של מצב a.
עבור כל פונקציה f מהצורה הזו, תמיד תהיה מטריצה ייחודית M שמקיימת את התנאי הזה
שאתם רואים כאן,
וזה שעל ידי הכפלת
M בוקטור ket a אנחנו מקבלים את הוקטור ket f של a,
וזה נכון לכל
בחירה של מצב קלאסי a.
זה לא כל כך קשה לכתוב
תיאור מפורש של M עבור כל פונקציה f
מהצורה הזו שבחרנו.
תמיד יהיה בה בדיוק
אחד אחד בכל עמודה עם כל רשומה אחרת שווה לאפס.
והנה הנוסחה. הרשומה b, a של M שווה לאחד אם b שווה ל-f של a
ואחרת, היא שווה לאפס, ובזה אנחנו מתכוונים
שזו הרשומה של M ששורה שלה מתאימה ל-b
ועמודה שלה מתאימה ל-a.
נראה כמה דוגמאות בעוד רגע, ונראה למה הנוסחה הזו עובדת.
עכשיו, אולי לא ברור למה נרצה לקחת פונקציה ולבטא אותה כמטריצה ככה,
אבל זה כן הגיוני לעשות את זה. אחת הסיבות, ואולי זו הסיבה העיקרית, היא שאם יש לנו מערכת
במצב הסתברותי
ואנחנו מבצעים פעולה דטרמיניסטית
על המערכת הזו, אז המצב ההסתברותי
שמתקבל יכול להתקבל
על ידי כפל מטריצה-וקטור, כלומר, אם המערכת שלנו
במצב הסתברותי
שמיוצג על ידי
וקטור הסתברות כלשהו v ואנחנו מבצעים את הפעולה הדטרמיניסטית
שמתוארת על ידי M
על המערכת הזו, אז המצב ההסתברותי שיתקבל יהיה M כפול v.
כאן, דרך אגב, החץ הזה עם
הפס הקטן עליו ככה הוא פשוט סימון נפוץ במתמטיקה להראות איך דבר אחד
ממופה ל
או הופך לדבר אחר. אפשר להשתמש בחץ רגיל, אבל זה מקובל
וזה מזוהה ואולי זה קצת יותר ספציפי מסתם חץ, שיכול להיות לו הרבה משמעויות שונות.
עכשיו בואו נסתכל על דוגמה או אוסף של דוגמאות, בעצם.
בואו נבחן מה קורה כשאנחנו לוקחים את קבוצת המצבים הקלאסיים סיגמא שלנו להיות שוב האלפבית הבינארי.
אין יותר מדי פונקציות שונות מהצורה שדנו בה כשזו קבוצת המצבים הקלאסיים שלנו וליתר דיוק, יש בדיוק ארבע
פונקציות מהצורה הזו.
כאן, ארבע הפונקציות האלה מתוארות על ידי מה שנקרא טבלאות הערכים שלהן.
הטבלה הראשונה מתארת
את הפונקציה הראשונה, שקראנו לה f1.
עבור כל קלט אפשרי בצד שמאל, אנחנו רושמים את הפלט
המתאים בצד ימין, אז f1 של אפס שווה לאפס,
ו-f1 של אחד, שוב, שווה לאפס, כלומר ש-f1 היא
הפונקציה הקבועה אפס.
היא תמיד מקבלת את הערך אפס.
הפונקציה השנייה f2
היא פונקציית הזהות.
הפלט תמיד שווה לקלט כפי שאפשר לראות מהטבלה השנייה.
הפונקציה השלישית f3
מתוארת על ידי הטבלה השלישית.
f3 של אפס שווה לאחד, ו-f3 של אחד שווה לאפס.
הפונקציה הזו יותר
ידועה כפונקציית NOT או שלילה לוגית.
לפעמים אנחנו גם קוראים לה היפוך ביט כי היא הופכת אפס
לאחד ואחד לאפס.
הפונקציה האחרונה f4,
שוב, היא פונקציה קבועה בדיוק כמו הראשונה, אבל הפעם היא הפונקציה הקבועה אחד
כי היא תמיד מקבלת את הערך אחד.
ואלה ארבע הפונקציות היחידות מהאלפבית הבינארי לעצמו.
הנה ארבע המטריצות שמתאימות לארבע הפונקציות האלה שמתוארות על ידי
הנוסחה מקודם,
שאתם יכולים לראות כאן, ואם זה מעניין אתכם, אתם יכולים לעצור את הסרטון ולבדוק את זה.
רק תזכרו שעם מטריצות, סדר האינדקסים הוא תמיד שורות קודם, עמודות שני.
אז הרשומה b, a מתאימה
לשורה b ועמודה a או לשורה שמתאימה
למצב הקלאסי b
ולעמודה שמתאימה
למצב הקלאסי a.
אז למשל, אם נסתכל
על הפונקציה הראשונה, יש לנו ש-f1 של אפס שווה לאפס
ובהתאם, הרשומה
אפס, אפס של M1 שווה לאחד.
ואילו הרשומה אחד, אפס
שנמצאת כאן שווה לאפס, ואפשר לעשות את אותו הדבר למקרה
שבו הקלט שווה לאחד ובאופן דומה, לשלוש
הפונקציות האחרות.
אתם יכולים גם לבדוק שהנוסחה
הזו מקודם נכונה ואתם יכולים פשוט לעבור אחד אחד על כל
האפשרויות השונות כדי לאמת את זה.
ולמעשה, אם אתם חושבים על הדרך שבה
כפל מטריצות עובד, באמת אפשר פשוט לראות את זה בעין.
כשאתם כופלים מטריצה בוקטור בסיס סטנדרטי ככה, אתם יכולים לדמיין שאתם
לוקחים את הקלט
ומורידים אותו
לתוך החלק העליון של אחת המטריצות בכל עמודה שמתאימה
למצב הקלאסי
שבתוך ה-ket, והפלט שאתם
מקבלים הוא פשוט העמודה הזו כוקטור הסתברות.
אז למשל, M3 כפול ket
אפס נותן לכם אפס, אחד
כוקטור הסתברות, שהוא ket אחד.
M3 כפול ket
אחד נותן לכם אחד, אפס, שהוא ket אפס וכן הלאה.
נדון בפעולות על
מצבים הסתברותיים יותר בעוד רגע, אבל קודם, בואו נציג את החלק השני של סימון Dirac.
זה הולך לעזור
לדבר על פעולות ולחשוב עליהן כמטריצות, וזה גם הולך להיות כלי סטנדרטי
שנמשיך להשתמש בו בהמשך. ההגדרה היא בדיוק כמו קודם.
יש לנו כל קבוצת מצבים קלאסיים סיגמא שאנחנו עובדים איתה ואנחנו מניחים שיש לנו דרך כלשהי
לסדר את המצבים הקלאסיים האלה.
אנחנו אז כותבים את הדבר
הזה שאתם רואים כאן שבו הפעם
הפס הזוויתי נמצא בצד שמאל ולא בצד ימין כדי להתכוון
לוקטור השורה שיש בו אחד
ברשומה ש
מתאימה ל-a ואפס לכל שאר הרשומות שמתאימות לכל
שאר המצבים הקלאסיים.
אז ההבדל בין
הדבר הזה ל-ket a הוא שזה וקטור שורה ו-
ket a הוא וקטור עמודה,
אבל מלבד זאת, הוקטורים
מוגדרים בצורה דומה.
אנחנו קוראים לזה bra a, אני לא בטוח אם זה
אמור להיות מצחיק, אבל הרעיון הוא ששמות bra ו-ket
הם שני חצאים של המילה bracket, ויהיה לנו עוד מה לומר
על זה בעוד רגע.
אבל קודם, בואו נסתכל
על דוגמה ממש מהירה.
עבור האלפבית הבינארי, יש לנו ש-bra אפס הוא
וקטור השורה הזה כאן בדומה ל-ket a,
חוץ מזה שהוא וקטור שורה
במקום וקטור עמודה ו-bra אחד הוא הוקטור הזה כאן.
עכשיו באופן כללי, אם אנחנו כופלים וקטור
שורה בוקטור עמודה, פשוט חושבים על אלה כמטריצות
שבמקרה יש להן רק
שורה אחת או עמודה אחת, אז אנחנו מקבלים מטריצה אחד על אחד, שאפשר לחשוב
עליה כסקלר.
כאן, דרך אגב, חשבו
על הכוכביות האלה כמייצגות מספרים שרירותיים.
בפרט, אם אנחנו
כופלים את וקטור השורה bra a בוקטור העמודה ket b,
אז יש שני דברים שיכולים לקרות.
אחד הוא ש-a ו-b שווים, אז הם אותו מצב קלאסי, ובמקרה הזה, האחדות ייתאמו
והמכפלה תהיה שווה לאחד או שיכול להיות
ש-a ו-b שונים,
ואז האחדות לא ייתאמו והמכפלה שווה לאפס.
דרך פשוטה לבטא
את התצפיות האלה היא ככה כאן.
ורק כדי לשמור על סדר, אנחנו כותבים את המכפלה הזו ככה עם רק פס אחד באמצע וזה אומר בדיוק אותו
דבר כמו זה כאן.
ועכשיו אתם יכולים לראות איך
ה-bra וה-ket מתחברים יחד ליצור bracket, שנקרא גם
מכפלה פנימית,
וזה משהו
שמאוד חשוב שנחזור אליו
בשיעור מספר שלוש.
כפל של וקטור
עמודה בוקטור שורה, מצד שני, נותן לנו מטריצה כפי שאתם רואים כאן.
אז למשל, אם נחזור שוב
לאלפבית הבינארי, אם נכפול ket אפס ב-bra אפס,
מה שנקבל הוא המטריצה הזו כאן, ואנחנו יכולים לעבור
על שאר האפשרויות כדי לראות מה קורה.
Ket אפס כפול bra אחד נותן
לנו את המטריצה הזו כאן שבה האחד עכשיו זז
למיקום הזה.
Ket אחד, bra אפס נראה ככה והנה ket אחד, bra אחד.
מה שאנחנו רואים שקורה הוא שיש רק אחד בודד במטריצה שכולה אפסים מלבד זה, והמיקום של האחד הזה
נקבע על ידי אילו
מצבים קלאסיים אנחנו בוחרים ב-bra וב-ket.
ליתר דיוק, וזה
נכון באופן כללי, לכל בחירה של קבוצת מצבים קלאסיים, המטריצה שנקבל על ידי
כפל ket a ב-bra b
היא המטריצה עם אחד ברשומה a, b ואפס לכל שאר הרשומות.
ועכשיו שיש לנו גם את
החלק הראשון וגם את השני של סימון Dirac, יש לנו כלי מאוד שימושי לחבר בין פעולות למטריצות.
אז בואו נחזור בקצרה
לפעולות דטרמיניסטיות ונזכור שקצת
קודם בשיעור,
נאמר שלכל פונקציה f מ
הצורה הזו כאן, יש לנו פעולה דטרמיניסטית שהופכת a ל-f של a
לכל מצב קלאסי אפשרי a. ואמרנו שלכל
פונקציה כזו, תמיד יש מטריצה ייחודית
M שפועלת ככה
על מצבי בסיס סטנדרטי.
באמצעות סימון Dirac, עכשיו אנחנו יכולים בקלות רבה לבטא את המטריצה הזו כפי שאתם רואים כאן,
ואנחנו יכולים לראות איך לפעמים
אפשר לעבוד עם מטריצות לחלוטין
בתוך המסגרת של סימון Dirac
בלי אף פעם להמיר במפורש
לוקטורים ומטריצות, כלומר מלבנים מלאים במספרים.
במקרה הזה, אנחנו יכולים לבדוק שהנוסחה
הנדרשת נכונה על ידי כפל M ב-ket a.
אנחנו מציבים את
הביטוי שלנו עבור M ככה ואנחנו יכולים להוריד את הסוגריים ולהצמיד את bra
b עם ket a ככה.
וזה בגלל שכפל
מטריצות הוא ליניארי, במקרה הזה, בארגומנט הראשון והוא אסוציאטיבי אז אנחנו יכולים להוריד את הסוגריים.
ועכשיו, נזכור שיש לנו a קבוע שאנחנו מדברים עליו כשאנחנו סוכמים על כל
הבחירות האפשריות של b,
ה-bracket הזה כאן
תמיד יהיה שווה לאפס כש-b לא שווה ל-a, אז לא תהיה
תרומה לסכום,
וכש-b שווה ל-a, ה-bracket יהיה שווה לאחד ואז נישאר עם
האיבר הבודד הזה כאן.
זו הנוסחה שרצינו ואז יש לנו דרך מאוד יפה ופשוטה לבטא פונקציה כמטריצה.
בנוסף לפעולות דטרמיניסטיות, יש לנו גם פעולות ש
בעצמן מכניסות אקראיות או אי-ודאות לגבי
המצב הקלאסי של מערכת.
אנחנו משתמשים במונח פעולה הסתברותית כדי להתכוון לפעולות כאלה, וליתר דיוק, כשאנחנו אומרים פעולה הסתברותית,
אנחנו מתכוונים לפעולות ש
יכולות להכניס אקראיות, אז פעולות דטרמיניסטיות הן בעצם מקרה פרטי
של פעולות הסתברותיות
שפשוט לא מזדמן להן
להכניס אקראיות.
הנה דוגמה פשוטה שבה
קצת אקראיות מוכנסת.
זו פעולה על ביט בודד. הדרך שבה היא עובדת היא שאם המצב הקלאסי
של הביט הוא אפס,
אז לא קורה כלום. הביט נשאר אפס, אבל אם המצב
הקלאסי של הביט הוא אחד, אז הפעולה הופכת את הביט לאפס
עם הסתברות ששווה ל-1/2.
אין שם מיוחד
לפעולה הזו, לפחות לא שאני מכיר.
זו רק דוגמה, אבל אתם יכולים לדמיין ביצוע
של הפעולה הזו על ביט.
בדיוק כמו פעולות דטרמיניסטיות, פעולות הסתברותיות אפשר
לייצג על ידי מטריצות והפעולה שלהן על מצבים הסתברותיים
ניתנת על ידי כפל מטריצה-וקטור בדיוק כמו קודם.
הפעם, לא בהכרח שלמטריצות יש בדיוק אחד אחד בכל עמודה ואפסים אחרת.
פעולות הסתברותיות
מיוצגות באופן כללי יותר על ידי מטריצות סטוכסטיות.
אלה מטריצות שכל הרשומות שלהן הן
מספרים ממשיים אי-שליליים ושהרשומות בכל
עמודה מסתכמות לאחד.
זה שקול לומר
שמטריצות סטוכסטיות הן מטריצות שבהן כל עמודה
יוצרת וקטור הסתברות.
זה הגיוני כשחושבים על
הפעולה של מטריצה על וקטור בסיס סטנדרטי.
אתם מתייחסים לכל
מצב קלאסי שתרצו ומדמיינים שמורידים את המצב הזה לתוך החלק העליון של המטריצה בכל עמודה שמתאימה
למצב הקלאסי הזה,
והעמודה הזו אומרת לכם מה
המצב ההסתברותי שיוצא כוקטור הסתברות.
הפעולה ההסתברותית
בדוגמה שלנו, למשל, מתוארת על ידי המטריצה הזו כאן.
אם נבצע את הפעולה הזו
על המצב הקלאסי אפס, אז המצב ההסתברותי שנקבל ניתן על ידי העמודה הראשונה,
שזה, שוב, המצב הקלאסי אפס או באופן שקול, המצב ההסתברותי
שבו אפס מתרחש עם הסתברות אחד.
אם במקום זאת, נבצע את הפעולה הזו על המצב הקלאסי אחד, אז אנחנו למעשה פשוט מאקרנים את הביט ובהתאם, נקבל
את וקטור ההסתברות הזה כאן
שבו ההסתברות לכל אחד
מהמצבים האפשריים שווה ל-1/2.
באופן כללי, אם נבצע את הפעולה הזו על כל מצב הסתברותי, אז ההשפעה היא בעיקרון
רק ממוצע משוקלל בין שתי העמודות
כי ככה כפל
מטריצה-וקטור עובד.
הוא ליניארי, אז אנחנו פשוט ממצעים את שתי
התוצאות האפשריות בהתאם.
כשאנחנו חושבים על פעולות
הסתברותיות בצורה הזו, טבעי לחשוב
עליהן כפוטנציאלית מכניסות או מזריקות אקראיות.
אנחנו יכולים פשוט לקרוא את העמודות אחת אחת ולראות את האקראיות
שהן מכניסות עבור כל מצב קלאסי אפשרי.
אפשר גם לחשוב על
פעולות הסתברותיות בצורה קצת שונה, שהיא שהן בחירות אקראיות של פעולות דטרמיניסטיות.
למשל, בדוגמה שלנו, אפשר לחשוב על הפעולה הזו כשקולה ל
הטלת מטבע הוגן
וביצוע או של
פונקציית האפס הקבועה או של פונקציית הזהות
כל אחת עם הסתברות 1/2,
ואתם יכולים לראות את זה משתקף
כאן במשוואה הזו.
זה תמיד אפשרי עבור
כל פעולה הסתברותית, וזה די אינטואיטיבי.
אם עשיתם בחירות אקראיות
כחלק מתהליך כלשהו, תמיד אפשר לדמיין שעושים את הבחירות האקראיות האלה מראש
ואז מקודדים אותן
לתוך אוסף כלשהו של פעולות דטרמיניסטיות.
לפעמים מאוד עוזר לחשוב על פעולות
הסתברותיות בצורה הזו, ונראה דוגמה
לזה בהמשך הדרך בעוד כמה שיעורים.
הדבר האחרון לומר
על מידע קלאסי בשיעור הזה נוגע להרכבת
פעולות הסתברותיות, שפירושו פשוט ביצוע
אחת אחרי השנייה.
בואו נניח שיש
לנו מערכת כלשהי בשם X ו-M1 עד Mn הן מטריצות סטוכסטיות שמייצגות פעולות
הסתברותיות על X.
דמיינו קודם שיש לנו
וקטור הסתברות v, שמייצג מצב הסתברותי
של X ברגע מסוים, ואז קודם כל מפעילים
את הפעולה ההסתברותית הראשונה על X, שמיוצגת על ידי המטריצה M1, ואז מפעילים את הפעולה
ההסתברותית השנייה,
שמיוצגת על ידי M2.
אם עושים את זה, אז
וקטור ההסתברות שמתקבל אחרי הפעלת רק הפעולה
הראשונה הוא M1 כפול v,
ואז כשמפעילים
את הפעולה השנייה, וקטור ההסתברות שמתקבל הוא M2 כפול כל וקטור שקיבלנו
אחרי הפעלת M1. אז זה נראה ככה.
עכשיו, כפל מטריצות
הוא פעולה אסוציאטיבית, שאומרת שלא משנה איפה שמים את הסוגריים.
אז אפשר באותה קלות
לשים את הסוגריים ככה.
זה מאוד פשוט, אבל זה גם מעניין כי זה חושף שאנחנו
יכולים לחשוב על הפעולה שבה קודם מפעילים M1
ואז מפעילים M2
כפעולה בודדת.
במילים אחרות,
הפעולה ההסתברותית שמתקבלת מהרכבת הפעולה
ההסתברותית הראשונה והשנייה מיוצגת על ידי
מכפלת המטריצות, M2 כפול M1,
וזו אותה פעולה ללא קשר למצב ההסתברותי
שאיתו התחלנו.
אנחנו לא צריכים לדעת שום דבר על וקטור ההסתברות v כדי לחשוב על או לתאר
את הפעולה המורכבת הזו.
שימו לב שהסדר
כאן הוא M2 בצד שמאל ו-M1 בצד ימין, וזה בגלל ש
המטריצה בצד ימין, M1,
היא זו ש
נכפלת בוקטור v, ואילו M2 נכפלת
בכל וקטור שנקבל אחרי כפל ב-M1.
אז תמיד צריך לזכור שהסדר במובן מסוים
מתהפך.
הפעולה שמבוצעת
קודם היא זו בצד ימין והפעולה שמבוצעת אחרונה או במקרה הזה, שנייה,
היא זו בצד שמאל.
אם אנחנו לא עוצרים בפעולה השנייה ומפעילים את כולן
בסדר מהראשונה ועד האחרונה, שהיא Mn,
אז ההרכבה של כל
הפעולות האלה ביחד ניתנת על ידי המכפלה
שאתם רואים כאן,
ואתם רואים שהסדר
שוב מתהפך מאותה סיבה בדיוק כמו קודם.
אז בקיצור, הרכבות
של פעולות הסתברותיות מיוצגות על ידי מכפלות
של מטריצות סטוכסטיות שמייצגות אותן.
תוך זכירה שזהו
סדר המטריצות במכפלה.
תמיד תקבלו מטריצה סטוכסטית על ידי לקיחת מכפלה של
מטריצות סטוכסטיות ככה, ולפעמים אנחנו מבטאים את העובדה הזו
באמירה שהמטריצות
הסטוכסטיות סגורות תחת כפל, והדרך
לחשוב על זה היא שלא ניתן לצאת מ
קבוצת המטריצות הסטוכסטיות
על ידי כפל שלהן כי הקבוצה סגורה.
נחזור לסדר
המטריצות במכפלה הזו, חשוב לציין ש
הסדר באמת משנה.
כפל מטריצות הוא לא קומוטטיבי. אם משנים את סדר
המטריצות במכפלה, אפשר לשנות את התוצאה,
ואנחנו לא צריכים לחפש רחוק מעבר לפעולות הדטרמיניסטיות
כדי לראות את זה.
הנה דוגמה פשוטה של
שתי מטריצות סטוכסטיות, ששתיהן מייצגות
פעולות דטרמיניסטיות שבהן הסדר משנה.
M1 מייצגת את פונקציית האפס הקבועה. בהנחה שאנחנו מדמיינים ששתי הפעולות האלה הן על ביטים, בדיוק כמו בדוגמה מקודם.
M2 מייצגת את פעולת ה-NOT
או היפוך ביט.
אם מבצעים M1 קודם
ואז מבצעים M2, התוצאה היא המטריצה הזו כאן, שמייצגת את
פונקציית האחד הקבועה.
אם מגדירים ביט לאפס
ואז הופכים אותו, זה אותו דבר כמו פשוט
להגדיר את הביט הזה לאחד.
מצד שני, אם מבצעים M2 קודם
ואז מבצעים M1, זו התוצאה כאן,
וזה הגיוני כי אם הופכים ביט
ואז מגדירים אותו לאפס, זה אותו דבר כמו
פשוט להגדיר אותו לאפס.
לא משנה שהפכתם אותו. ברור ששתי
המטריצות האלה לא זהות, ואז יש לנו דוגמה
מאוד פשוטה שחושפת
שהסדר כן משנה. כמובן, זה לא מפתיע בכלל.
כולנו יודעים שהסדר שבו
פעולות מבוצעות משנה או לפחות, הוא יכול להשנות.
למשל, אם מדליקים
גפרור ואז נושפים עליו, התוצאה מאוד שונה
מלנשוף על הגפרור קודם
ואז להדליק אותו. בשלב הזה, דיברנו לא מעט
על מידע קלאסי ועכשיו הגיע הזמן סוף סוף ל
דון במידע קוונטי.
ומה שנגלה הוא ש
מבחינה מתמטית, מידע קוונטי עובד
בצורה מאוד דומה למידע קלאסי
עם כמה הבדלים מהותיים.
ההבדל המהותי הראשון
הוא ממש בהתחלה, איך מגדירים מצב, במקרה הזה, מצב קוונטי של מערכת,
ויש מובן שבו הבחירה האחת הזו, איך
מגדירים מצב קוונטי, קובעת במידה רבה איך
מידע קוונטי עובד.
נגדיר גם איך
מדידות ופעולות עובדות, ובשיעור הבא, נדון באיך
מידע קוונטי עובד לא רק עבור מערכות בודדות
אלא עבור מערכות מרובות,
אבל הדברים האלה בעצם
נובעים די טבעית ברגע שהמושג של מצב קוונטי של מערכת בודדת ב
בידוד הוכח.
הנה ההגדרה. מצב קוונטי של מערכת מיוצג על ידי וקטור עמודה שהאינדקסים שלו מוצבים
בהתאמה עם
המצבים הקלאסיים של אותה מערכת.
אז אנחנו מניחים כאן ש
המערכת שאנחנו מדברים עליה יש לה קבוצה כלשהי של מצבים קלאסיים, בדיוק כמו שדיברנו
על מידע קלאסי
ומצבים הסתברותיים. הרשומות בוקטור מצב קוונטי
הן מספרים מרוכבים בניגוד למקרה ההסתברותי
שבו הרשומות הן
מספרים ממשיים אי-שליליים.
והפעם, הסכום של הערכים
המוחלטים בריבוע של הרשומות חייב להיות שווה לאחד בניגוד לסכום שווה לאחד
כפי שיש לנו במקרה ההסתברותי.
המספרים המרוכבים שמופיעים
בוקטור מצב קוונטי נקראים לפעמים אמפליטודות והם ממלאים תפקיד ש
דומה להסתברויות,
אבל הם לא הסתברויות ואין להם את
אותו הפירוש.
עכשיו, אני לא יכול לתת לכם סיבה טובה למה מצבים קוונטיים
צריכים להיות מוגדרים ככה מלבד לומר ש
פיזיקאים גילו
שההגדרה הזו
רלוונטית פיזיקלית והיא מאפשרת לנו לתאר ולמדל
מערכות מכניקה קוונטית.
במילים אחרות, אנחנו בוחרים בהגדרה הזו
כי היא עובדת, לא כי יש
סיבות מסוימות למה מצבים קוונטיים צריכים
להיות מוגדרים ככה.
ביחס ל
מתמטיקה של המושג הזה של מצב קוונטי, הצעד הראשון להבנה שלו ועבודה איתו הוא
לזכור את ההגדרה הזו
של הנורמה האוקלידית של וקטור, שאפשר לחשוב עליה גיאומטרית כאורך של וקטור, בדיוק כמו שהייתם חושבים על האורך
של וקטור ממשי דו-ממדי אם הייתם מציירים אותו על דף
נייר כחץ שיוצא מהראשית בצורה הרגילה.
ספציפית, אם יש לנו
וקטור עמודה v כזה, שאנחנו מניחים שיש לו
רשומות של מספרים מרוכבים, אלפא אחד עד אלפא n,
אז הנורמה האוקלידית של v מוגדרת כפי שאתם רואים כאן.
זה הסימון שאנחנו
משתמשים בו לנורמה האוקלידית, שמים את הפסים הכפולים האלה סביב כל וקטור שאנחנו מדברים עליו.
במקרה הזה, זה v, והדרך שבה הנורמה האוקלידית מוגדרת היא שהיא השורש הריבועי של הסכום
של הערכים המוחלטים בריבוע
של הרשומות של הוקטור.
אז דרך נוספת להגדיר מה
וקטור מצב קוונטי הוא זה שוקטור מצב קוונטי הוא וקטור עמודה עם
רשומות של מספרים מרוכבים
שהנורמה האוקלידית שלו שווה לאחד, כלומר שהוא וקטור יחידה ביחס לנורמה האוקלידית.
זה בגלל שסכום
הערכים המוחלטים בריבוע שווה לאחד אם ורק אם הנורמה
האוקלידית שווה לאחד.
השורש הריבועי לא משנה כלום כשסכום הערכים
המוחלטים בריבוע שווה לאחד.
אז זה מה שוקטור מצב קוונטי הוא. הוא וקטור עמודה עם אינדקסים שמתאימים ל
מצבים הקלאסיים של מערכת
עם רשומות של מספרים מרוכבים ונורמה אוקלידית שווה לאחד.
מה שזה אומר או מה שזה מרמז או איך צריך לפרש את
המושג הזה זה עניין אחר ובמובן מסוים,
חקר מידע
קוונטי וחישוב הוא חקירה של מה
שההגדרה הזו מרמזת, לפחות מבחינת
עיבוד מידע.
זו פשוט נקודת ההתחלה.
כהערת אגב, תנו לי לציין שיש
נורמות אחרות חוץ מהנורמה האוקלידית והסימון הזה
כאן עם הפסים הכפולים
סביב וקטור לא תמיד
אומר נורמה אוקלידית.
בהקשרים שונים, הסימון הזה יכול להתייחס
לנורמה אחרת.
למשל, הסכום
של הערכים המוחלטים בלי ריבועים או שורש
ריבועי הוא נורמה אחרת,
שנקראת לעתים קרובות נורמת אחד. יש לא מעט
נורמות שונות, למעשה.
לפעמים תראו
את הסימון הזה בשימוש עם תחתית אחרי
סט הפסים השני שנותנת יותר מידע על איזו נורמה אנחנו מדברים עליה.
וכשאנחנו עושים את זה, די טיפוסי שהמספר שתיים כתחתית
אומר נורמה אוקלידית.
אבל בסדרה הזו, בכל פעם שיש לנו
וקטור עמודה כזה, סימון הפסים הכפולים הזה לבד
אומר נורמה אוקלידית.
הנה כמה דוגמאות
של וקטורי מצב קוונטי והוקטורים האלה ספציפית הם וקטורי מצב של qubit,
מה שאומר ש
המצבים הקלאסיים של המערכת שלנו הם אפס ואחד.
המילה qubit היא קיצור של ביט קוונטי, שזה באמת פשוט ביט
שיכול להיות במצב קוונטי.
שתי הדוגמאות הראשונות ממש פשוטות. וקטורי הבסיס הסטנדרטי
ket אפס ו-ket אחד הם וקטורי מצב קוונטי.
שניהם וקטורי עמודה, והאינדקסים מתאימים
למצבים הקלאסיים אפס ואחד, והרשומות של
הוקטורים האלה הן מספרים מרוכבים.
עבור הוקטורים הספציפיים האלה, הרשומות הן אפס ואחד, שהם מספרים ממשיים, ולמעשה, הם שלמים, אבל הם גם מספרים מרוכבים
שבמקרה יש להם
חלק מדומה שווה לאפס.
לכל וקטור יש רשומה אחת שווה לאחד ורשומה אחת שווה לאפס.
אז כשסוכמים את הערכים
המוחלטים של הרשומות, מקבלים אחד בשני המקרים.
אז התנאים
הנדרשים כדי שהוקטורים האלה יהיו וקטורי מצב קוונטי מתקיימים.
שתי הדוגמאות הבאות הן מצבי qubit שנפגשים מאוד לעתים קרובות שנקראים מצב הפלוס ומצב המינוס.
הם מסומנים כפי
שאתם רואים כאן על המסך, או עם ket פלוס
או ket מינוס ככה, והם מוגדרים
כפי שאתם יכולים לראות כאן.
שוב, הרשומות של
הוקטורים האלה הן מספרים מרוכבים. הפעם, הן או פלוס אחד חלקי שורש ריבועי של שתיים או מינוס אחד חלקי שורש ריבועי של שתיים,
וכשסוכמים את
הערכים המוחלטים בריבוע, מקבלים 1/2 ועוד 1/2, שזה אחד.
דרך אגב, לשים
סימן פלוס או מינוס בתוך ket ככה
עלול להיראות קצת מוזר כי אלה לא מצבים
קלאסיים של המערכת שלנו,
אבל הסימון הזה משמש בכל זאת, ונחזור לזה בעוד רגע.
אבל לעכשיו, בקיצור, אנחנו יכולים להשתמש בסימון Dirac כדי לשים כל שם שנרצה עבור וקטור בתוך ket.
הוקטור לא חייב להיות
וקטור בסיס סטנדרטי כשאנחנו משתמשים בסימון Dirac.
הנה דוגמה אחרונה של מצב qubit
לרגע, לפחות.
זה וקטור מצב קוונטי של qubit שאין לו שם מיוחד, והוא לא במיוחד משמעותי.
הרשומות של הוקטור הזה הן אחד ועוד פעמיים i
חלקי שלוש ומינוס 2/3.
אלה מספרים מרוכבים, ואם מחשבים את
הערכים המוחלטים בריבוע של שתי הרשומות האלה, מקבלים 5/9 עבור הראשונה
ו-4/9 עבור השנייה. אז סכום הערכים
המוחלטים בריבוע שווה לאחד.
והנה דוגמה אחרונה. הפעם עבור מערכת
שהמצבים הקלאסיים שלה הם ארבעת סמלי הקלפים.
אני לא יודע למה הייתה לנו מערכת שהמצבים הקלאסיים שלה
הם ארבעת סמלי הקלפים במצב קוונטי, אבל זה אפשרי עקרונית
וזה סתם נועד כדוגמה.
הרשומות שמתאימות
לסמלים השונים הן 1/2 לתלתן, מינוס
i חלקי שתיים ליהלום,
אפס ללב כי הוא לא מופיע בסכום ואחד חלקי שורש
ריבועי של שתיים לעלה.
והנה איך זה נראה
כוקטור עמודה, בהנחה שסידרנו
את המצבים הקלאסיים כפי שעשינו קודם,
שזה הסדר
שאתם רואים כאן.
לקיחת הערך המוחלט
בריבוע של הרשומות האלה נותנת רבע לראשונה, גם רבע לשנייה.
הערך המוחלט בריבוע
של אפס שווה לאפס, אז הרשומה הזו לא
תורמת לסכום.
ולבסוף, לאחרונה, מקבלים 1/2. אז הסכום שווה לאחד כפי שנדרש כדי שהוקטור הזה
יהיה וקטור מצב קוונטי.
עכשיו לפני רגע, השתמשנו בסימון
ket פלוס ו-ket מינוס כדי להתייחס לשני וקטורי מצב qubit שאינם וקטורי בסיס סטנדרטי.
ואני רוצה לחזור
לנקודה הזו בקצרה ולהסביר איך סימון Dirac משמש עבור וקטורים שרירותיים ולא רק עבור וקטורי בסיס סטנדרטי.
כפי שכבר ציינתי, אנחנו יכולים להשתמש בכל שם
שנרצה בתוך bra או ket כדי להתייחס לוקטור.
Kets הם וקטורי עמודה
ו-bras הם וקטורי שורה בדיוק כמו קודם.
כדוגמה, האות היוונית
פסי נפוצה מאוד בתוך ket כדי להתייחס לוקטור שרירותי כלשהו,
וכאן, אנחנו משתמשים בה כדי
לתת שם לוקטור המצב מקודם שאין
לו שם מיוחד.
כשאנחנו עושים את זה, לאות פסי לא
בהכרח יש משמעות בפני עצמה.
זה פשוט שם של וקטור, והוא בתוך ket כדי לעזור לנו להבהיר
שזה וקטור עמודה.
זה יכול להיות קצת
מבלבל לפעמים, ויש פוטנציאל לדו-משמעות אם האות פסי יכולה להיות משויכת
למצב קלאסי של
מערכת כלשהי למשל, אבל בדרך כלל זה לא
גורם לבעיות, ולא חייבים להשתמש
בסימון Dirac ככה
אם לא רוצים. שימוש באות קטנה כמו
u, v, או w בלי ket הוא גם דרך בסדר גמור
לסמן וקטור עמודה
או ליתר דיוק,
וקטור מצב קוונטי.
הבחירה שלכם באיזה סימון
להשתמש כדי לבטא את עצמכם.
רק צריכים לוודא
שמספר אחד, המשמעות של מה שאתם
מנסים לבטא ברורה לאחרים.
ומספר שתיים, שאתם מבינים מה
אחרים מנסים לבטא גם כשההעדפות שלהם לסימון לא זהות לשלכם.
יש כלל אחד מאוד חשוב לשימוש בסימון Dirac
עבור וקטורים שרירותיים וזה שאם יש לכם
וקטור עמודה
שהחלטתם לכתוב
כ-ket פסי, למשל, או שזה יכול להיות שם
אחר בתוך ket, אז וקטור השורה bra פסי
מובן כ
הטרנספוז הצמוד של הוקטור ket פסי.
וכאן, זה כתוב כמשוואה שבה הפגיון הזה כאן מתייחס לטרנספוז הצמוד.
מה שזה ספציפית הוא
וקטור השורה שמקבלים על ידי, מספר אחד, טרנספוזיציה של הוקטור, כלומר שהופכים
את הוקטור על הצד ומשנים אותו מעמודה לשורה
בלי לשנות בעצם את הרשומות. ומספר שתיים, לקיחת הצמוד המרוכב
של כל אחת מהרשומות.
אפשר בעצם לבצע
את שתי הפעולות האלה, הטרנספוז וה
צמוד המרוכב לפי רשומות בכל סדר או שתי
הפעולות האלה מתחלפות.
אז עבור הוקטור בדוגמה הזו, בהינתן שהחלטנו
לקרוא לוקטור הזה ket פסי, מובן ש-bra פסי
אומר הוקטור הזה כאן
שבו עשינו טרנספוז לוקטור על ידי הפיכת ket אפס ו-ket
אחד ל-bra אפס ו-bra אחד, ולקחנו את הצמוד
המרוכב של כל רשומה,
ולכן אחד ועוד
פעמיים i חלקי שלוש הפך לאחד מינוס פעמיים
i חלקי שלוש כאן.
הנה איך הוקטורים האלה נראים כשהם כתובים
במפורש כוקטור עמודה ווקטור שורה.
שימו לב, דרך אגב, ש
הכלל הזה עקבי עם הסימון שאנחנו משתמשים בו כשיש מצבים קלאסיים
בתוך ה-bra וה-ket.
במקרה הזה, הרשומות הן
כולן אפס חוץ מאחד בודד, ואז לקיחת הצמוד
המרוכב לא עושה כלום במקרה הזה.
ראינו עכשיו איך מצבים קוונטיים מיוצגים כוקטורים, אבל לא ברור בשלב
הזה מה המשמעות או ההשלכות
מבחינת מה
אפשר לעשות עם מערכת במצב קוונטי או איך אפשר לתקשר איתה.
הדבר הראשון שצריך לעשות כדי להביא את הנושאים האלה למוקד
הוא לדון במדידות.
באופן אינטואיטיבי,
מדידות מספקות מנגנון לחילוץ מידע
קלאסי ממערכות קוונטיות.
כשאנחנו מסתכלים על מערכת
כשהיא במצב קוונטי, אנחנו לא רואים מצב קוונטי בדיוק כמו שלא רואים
מצבים הסתברותיים,
אנחנו רואים מצבים קלאסיים, והמושג הזה של מדידה הוא מה שמספק את הממשק.
אם אנחנו, כבני אדם, רוצים לדעת משהו על מערכת קוונטית, אנחנו צריכים למדוד אותה, ובכך, נחלץ מידע קלאסי
על כל מצב קוונטי
שהמערכת הזו הייתה בו.
יש מושגים
שונים של מדידות. ההבדל הוא עניין
של כלליות באמת, ואנחנו נתחיל עם הפשוט והבסיסי ביותר,
שבדרך כלל נקרא
מדידת בסיס סטנדרטי.
נכליל את זה
בשיעורים הבאים. נדבר על מה שנקרא
מדידות הטלתיות בשיעור שלוש, ואז מאוחר יותר ב
יחידה השלישית של הסדרה,
נדבר על מדידות כלליות, שנקראות גם מדדי ערך
אופרטור חיובי או POVMs בקיצור.
אבל לעכשיו, נגביל את תשומת הלב שלנו למדידות בסיס סטנדרטי.
כשמדידה
מבוצעת על מערכת, תהיה קבוצה כלשהי
של תוצאות אפשריות של אותה מדידה, שהן תוצאות קלאסיות,
ובמקרה של
מדידת בסיס סטנדרטי, התוצאות האפשריות הן
בדיוק המצבים הקלאסיים של כל מערכת שנמדדת.
כל אחד מהמצבים הקלאסיים האלה יהיה תוצאת המדידה עם הסתברות כלשהי, וההסתברות הזו היא
הערך המוחלט בריבוע
של הרשומה שמתאימה
למצב הקלאסי הזה של כל וקטור מצב
קוונטי שהמערכת הייתה בו מיד לפני שנמדדה.
אנחנו יודעים שהערך המוחלט בריבוע של כל מספר מרוכב הוא מספר ממשי אי-שלילי, ואנחנו יודעים מההגדרה
של וקטורי מצב קוונטי
שסכום הערכים המוחלטים
בריבוע של הרשומות של וקטור מצב קוונטי שווה לאחד.
אז זה הגיוני. כל מצב קלאסי יופיע כתוצאה של
המדידה עם הסתברות כלשהי וההסתברויות מסתכמות לאחד.
הנה כמה דוגמאות. קודם כל, נניח שיש לנו
qubit במצב פלוס.
אם נמדוד את ה-qubit הזה ביחס למדידת
בסיס סטנדרטי, נקבל או אפס או
אחד כתוצאה.
ההסתברות לקבל אפס היא הערך המוחלט
בריבוע של אחד חלקי שורש שתיים, שזה 1/2, וזו אותה
הסתברות לקבל אחד.
אז אם מודדים מצב פלוס, מקבלים ביט אקראי אחיד.
אם המערכת במצב מינוס
ולא במצב פלוס, אז המדידה עובדת
בדיוק באותה צורה.
ההסתברויות הן, שוב, 1/2 לכל תוצאה אפשרית.
ההבדל היחיד כאן הוא שסימן הפלוס הפך לסימן מינוס, אבל כשלוקחים ערך
מוחלט, שום דבר לא משתנה.
אם מודדים את מצב ה-qubit הזה, ההסתברות לקבל את התוצאה אפס היא הערך המוחלט בריבוע של אחד ועוד פעמיים i
חלקי שלוש, שזה 5/9,
וההסתברות לקבל את התוצאה אחד היא הערך המוחלט בריבוע
של מינוס 2/3, שזה 4/9.
ולבסוף, מדידת
מצב הבסיס הסטנדרטי ket אפס נותנת את התוצאה
אפס בוודאות, ובאופן דומה, מדידת המצב ket אחד
נותנת את התוצאה אחד בוודאות. זה בגלל שהערך
המוחלט בריבוע של אחד הוא אחד.
בדומה למה שהיה לנו
בהגדרה ההסתברותית. אנחנו יכולים לשייך את המצבים הקוונטיים
האלה, ket אפס ו-ket אחד, לכך שהמערכת נמצאת
במצבים הקלאסיים האלה,
והדוגמה הזו עקבית
עם הפירוש הזה.
עכשיו, בדיוק כמו שהיה לנו
בהגדרה ההסתברותית, אם מודדים מערכת כש
היא במצב קוונטי,
אז המצב ישתנה, באופן כללי, כתוצאה מביצוע
המדידה הזו.
בפרט, ושוב, זה בדיוק כמו שהיה לנו
בהגדרה ההסתברותית.
אם מודדים מערכת והתוצאה של המדידה
היא המצב הקלאסי a, אז המצב הקוונטי
החדש של המערכת הופך ל-ket a.
אז עבור המצב הזה
כאן, למשל, אנחנו רואים את אותו סוג
של התנהגות שהיה לנו בהגדרה ההסתברותית.
אם מודדים אז עם הסתברות 5/9, מקבלים את התוצאה אפס, ובמקרה הזה, המצב
עובר ל-ket אפס,
ועם הסתברות
4/9, התוצאה היא אחד, והמצב עובר ל-ket אחד.
לפעמים התופעה הזו מכונה קריסה
של המצב הקוונטי, וזה סוג של
דבר ששומר על אנשים
שחוקרים את היסודות
של מכניקת הקוונטים ערים בלילה.
אבל מנקודת מבט
מתמטית גרידא, זה ממש פשוט
ומאוד אנלוגי למה שיש לנו במקרה ההסתברותי.
מקור המתח כאן, במובן מסוים, נוגע לטבע
הבסיסי של מצבים קוונטיים ומה הם מייצגים
ואיך הם שונים
ממצבים הסתברותיים. אבל ברמה מתמטית, זה אולי מה שהייתם מצפים לו.
שימו לב, דרך אגב, שאם
תמדדו פעם שנייה, תקבלו בדיוק
את אותה תוצאה כמו במדידה הראשונה.
אז יש גבול לכמה
מידע קלאסי אפשר לחלץ ממצב קוונטי, ונחזור לנקודה הזו בקרוב
בשיעור אחר. דיברנו על מצבים קוונטיים וגם על מדידות, ספציפית מדידות בסיס סטנדרטי,
שמספקות דרך
לחלץ מידע קלאסי ממצבים קוונטיים.
הנושא הנותר
לשיעור הזה הוא פעולות, ספציפית פעולות אוניטריות, שמתארות איך
מצבים קוונטיים של מערכות
יכולים להשתנות. באופן טבעי, בהינתן שוקטורי
מצב קוונטי שונים מוקטורי הסתברות, הייתם מצפים שקבוצת
הפעולות המותרות
על מצבים קוונטיים שונה ממה שיש לנו עבור
מידע קלאסי, ואכן, זה המצב.
בעוד שפעולות על מצבים הסתברותיים מיוצגות על ידי מטריצות סטוכסטיות, פעולות על וקטורי מצב קוונטי
מיוצגות על ידי מטריצות אוניטריות.
הנה ההגדרה של מטריצות אוניטריות.
מטריצה ריבועית U עם רשומות של מספרים
מרוכבים היא אוניטרית אם היא מקיימת את השוויונות
שאתם רואים כאן.
הפגיון מייצג
את הטרנספוז הצמוד, שכבר ראינו עבור וקטורים כשדיברנו על סימון
Dirac לפני כמה רגעים.
כאן אנחנו מבצעים את
הטרנספוז הצמוד על מטריצה ולא על וקטור, אבל זה בעיקרון אותו הדבר.
אנחנו עושים טרנספוז למטריצה, שפירושו פשוט
שמחליפים שורות ועמודות, אז הרשומה JK הופכת לרשומה KJ,
וגם לוקחים את הצמוד
המרוכב של כל רשומה.
בנוסף, הסימון הזה כאן
אומר מטריצת היחידה.
שני השוויונות האלה
כאן בעצם שקולים. אם יש לכם אחד, אז
אוטומטית יש לכם את השני.
שניהם שקולים
לומר ש-U הפיכה, וההופכית שווה
לטרנספוז הצמוד.
זה נכון רק עבור מטריצות
ריבועיות, דרך אגב. אם יש לכם מטריצה שאינה ריבועית, אז אחד משני
השוויונות האלה עשוי להיות נכון,
אבל אז השני לא יהיה נכון.
אבל כאן, אנחנו מדברים
על מטריצות ריבועיות.
אז זו ההגדרה הסטנדרטית
למטריצות אוניטריות, וזה נחמד כי קל לבדוק
אם מטריצה היא אוניטרית.
פשוט כופלים את המטריצה בטרנספוז הצמוד שלה מכל צד, ורואים אם מקבלים
את מטריצת היחידה.
יש דרך שקולה לאפיין מטריצות אוניטריות, והיא שמטריצה
ריבועית היא אוניטרית אם ורק אם היא אף פעם
לא משנה את הנורמה האוקלידית
של שום וקטור כשכופלים. מטריצה N על N U היא אוניטרית אם ורק אם
הנורמה האוקלידית של U כפול v
שווה לנורמה האוקלידית של v לכל וקטור עמודה n-ממדי v עם רשומות של מספרים מרוכבים.
ולכן, אם v הוא
וקטור מצב קוונטי, אז U כפול v הוא גם
וקטור מצב קוונטי כי וקטורי מצב קוונטי
הם פשוט הוקטורים שיש להם
נורמה אוקלידית שווה לאחד.
למעשה, אפשר לומר קצת יותר, שהמטריצות האוניטריות הן בדיוק המטריצות שתמיד הופכות
וקטורי מצב קוונטי
לוקטורי מצב קוונטי. זה מצב דומה למה שיש לנו עבור מטריצות סטוכסטיות
ווקטורי הסתברות.
המטריצות הסטוכסטיות
הן בדיוק המטריצות שתמיד הופכות וקטורי הסתברות לוקטורי הסתברות.
אז ברגע שהחלטנו שפעולות צריכות להיות מיוצגות על ידי מטריצות, שזה אותו דבר כמו לומר שטרנספורמציות פועלות ליניארית
על וקטורים שמייצגים מצבים, הבחירות האלה לקבוצות
הפעולות המותרות נובעות באופן טבעי, לפחות
במובן המתמטי.
עכשיו בואו נסתכל על כמה דוגמאות של פעולות אוניטריות על qubit.
נראה הרבה יותר דוגמאות
של פעולות אוניטריות בשיעורים הבאים, כולל פעולות אוניטריות על מערכות
עם יותר משני מצבים קלאסיים. אבל לעכשיו, נתמקד רק
בפעולות אוניטריות על qubit.
אנחנו הולכים לראות את
הדוגמאות הספציפיות האלה עולות שוב ושוב, אז בהחלט שווה להכיר
את הפעולות האלה.
אוסף הדוגמאות הראשון הוא מה שנקרא פעולות Pauli.
אלה הפעולות שמתאימות למטריצות Pauli, שמוצגות כאן.
כולן אוניטריות, ואפשר לבדוק את זה לכל אחת לפי ההגדרה מקודם.
המטריצות הספציפיות האלה
במקרה שוות לטרנספוז הצמוד שלהן עצמן, כלומר שהן
כולן מטריצות הרמיטיות.
אז לבדוק שהן
כולן אוניטריות, במקרה הזה, זה עניין של להעלות כל אחת בריבוע ולראות שהתוצאה
היא מטריצת היחידה.
השמות שאתם רואים
למטריצות האלה הם די סטנדרטיים, ותראו גם את
סיגמא x, סיגמא y, וסיגמא z נקראים פשוט X, Y, ו-Z.
אבל שימו לב ש
האותיות הגדולות X, Y, ו-Z נפוצות גם לשימושים אחרים, אפילו בהקשר של
מידע קוונטי,
אבל הן שמות מאוד נפוצים
למטריצות האלה.
פעולת סיגמא x או X
נקראת גם היפוך ביט או פעולת NOT, שכבר ראינו
בהקשר הקלאסי.
ופעולת סיגמא z או Z
נקראת גם היפוך פאזה.
וכאן, אפשר לראות את
הפעולה של הפעולות האלה על וקטורי הבסיס הסטנדרטי, מה שמסביר קצת
מאיפה השמות האלה באו.
בהחלט הגיוני
לקרוא לסיגמא x היפוך ביט בהתבסס על הפעולה הזו כאן.
היא פשוט הופכת את הביט מ
אפס לאחד או מאחד לאפס.
גם הגיוני
לקרוא לסיגמא z היפוך פאזה בהתבסס על הפעולה הזו כאן.
אבל אם זה לא לגמרי ברור
ברגע הזה, זה בסדר.
נפגוש את
הפעולה הזו שוב ושוב והמשמעות
של לשים סימן מינוס לפני וקטור הבסיס
ket אחד ולא ket אפס
ולמה זה נקרא היפוך פאזה יהיה יותר ברור מאוחר יותר.
הדוגמה הבאה היא
פעולת Hadamard, שמיוצגת על ידי
המטריצה הזו כאן, שכמעט תמיד נקראת H.
לבדוק ש-H אוניטרית היא שוב
חישוב פשוט, שאם אזוז מהדרך, תוכלו לראות כאן.
בדומה למטריצות Pauli, H היא הטרנספוז הצמוד של עצמה.
אז יש לנו את השוויון הזה כאן, וכשמבצעים את הכפל, מקבלים את מטריצת היחידה כנדרש.
הדוגמה השלישית היא
בעצם סוג שלם של פעולות אוניטריות
שנקראות פעולות פאזה.
אלה פעולות
שמיוצגות על ידי כל מטריצה שלוקחת את הצורה הזו
שאתם רואים כאן כאשר תטא הוא כל מספר ממשי.
אז הרשומה הזו כאן תמיד
תהיה מספר מרוכב כלשהו על מעגל היחידה.
מטריצות כאלה תמיד אוניטריות, מה שאני אשאיר לכם לאמת.
הפעם, הטרנספוז הצמוד לא יהיה שווה למטריצה המקורית אלא אם המספר הזה כאן הוא
אחד או מינוס אחד,
ובמקרה הזה, נגיע
או למטריצת היחידה או לסיגמא z, שכבר
פגשנו.
ספציפית, טרנספוזיציה
לא תעשה כלום למטריצה הזו, אבל לקיחת הצמוד
המרוכב של כל רשומה משנה את הרשומה הזו כאן
ל-e בחזקת מינוס i תטא.
שתי הפעולות הספציפיות האלה כאן הן דוגמאות חשובות במיוחד
של פעולות פאזה.
לראשונה, לוקחים
תטא להיות פאי חלקי שתיים, ומקבלים את המטריצה הזו כאן.
זו בדרך כלל נקראת
פעולת S או S gate כשמדברים על circuits, שלא נדון בהם בשיעור הזה,
אבל זה נושא חשוב
שמגיע בקרוב.
השנייה היא הפעולה הזו. זו פעולת T או T gate.
ולפעולה הזו, תטא
שווה לפאי חלקי ארבע. ואז כשמחשבים את האקספוננט, מקבלים את הערך הזה כאן, שהוא אחד ועוד i חלקי
שורש ריבועי של שתיים.
הנה רק כמה דוגמאות מהירות כדי לראות כמה מהפעולות
האלה בפעולה.
הנה הפעולה של
פעולת Hadamard על ket אפס ו-ket אחד.
אם עוברים על
כפל המטריצה-וקטור, רואים שמה שמקבלים הם מצב הפלוס ומצב
המינוס בהתאמה.
אם מבצעים את פעולת Hadamard על מצב הפלוס ומצב
המינוס, מצד שני, חוזרים חזרה ל-ket אפס ו-ket אחד.
אז אם מנקים קצת, אפשר לראות את הפעולה בצורה ברורה יותר.
פעולת Hadamard
הופכת הלוך ושוב בין מצב האפס למצב הפלוס ובין מצב האחד
למצב המינוס.
לגבי שתי המשוואות האלה כאן, שימו לב שזה נותן לנו דרך פשוטה לזהות את ההבדל בין מצב פלוס למצב מינוס.
כפי שראינו קודם בשיעור, אם מודדים מצב
פלוס ומצב מינוס ביחס ל
מדידת בסיס סטנדרטי,
מקבלים ביט אקראי אחיד בשני המקרים, מה שלא עוזר לנו
לזהות את ההבדל.
אבל אם מבצעים פעולת
Hadamard ואז מודדים, נראה אפס אם
המצב המקורי היה מצב פלוס
ואחד אם המצב
המקורי היה מצב מינוס.
אז שני המצבים האלה אכן שונים, ואפשר להבדיל ביניהם
בצורה מושלמת בשיטה שתיארתי הרגע,
שהיא קודם לבצע
פעולת Hadamard ואז למדוד.
נחזור לדוגמה של
מצב qubit שראינו קודם שאינו מיוחד במיוחד, אפשר לראות מה פעולת Hadamard
עושה למצב
על ידי המרה לצורות
שאתם רואים כאן וביצוע הכפל.
והנה התוצאה
שאפשר להמיר חזרה לסימון Dirac אם רוצים,
וזו דרך אחת לחשב
את הפעולות מהסוג הזה.
הנה דוגמה נוספת שממחישה שלא תמיד
צריך להמיר במפורש לצורת מטריצה-וקטור.
אפשר גם לבצע את
החישובים האלה ישירות באמצעות סימון Dirac.
הדוגמה הזו נוגעת לפעולת T, והנה היא
כאן רק בשביל הפנייה.
לפעולה הזו יש את הפעולה הזו כאן על מצבי בסיס סטנדרטי.
ואם אנחנו רוצים לחשב
את הפעולה של פעולת T על מצב פלוס, למשל, אפשר להתחיל בלפרוש את
ההגדרה של מצב הפלוס
ואז להשתמש בליניאריות
כדי לבטא את התוצאה כפי שאתם רואים כאן.
עכשיו אפשר פשוט להציב
את הביטויים האלה מלמעלה, לעשות קצת
פישוט לאיבר השני, ומקבלים את התוצאה.
אם מסיבה כלשהי נרצה להפעיל פעולת
Hadamard על התוצאה, אפשר לעשות דבר דומה.
קודם, מציבים את הביטוי עבור T שפועלת על מצב הפלוס ומשתמשים בליניאריות כמו שעשינו קודם.
ועכשיו, אם מציבים את
הביטויים שכבר יש לנו עבור פעולת Hadamard
שפועלת על ket אפס ו-ket אחד,
מקבלים את זה. ועכשיו, אפשר לפרוש את
מצב הפלוס ומצב המינוס כדי לקבל את הביטוי הזה כאן,
שאפשר לפשט פשוט על ידי חיבור, והנה התוצאה הסופית.
אין שום דבר מיוחד במיוחד
בדוגמה הזו. היא רק נועדה
להמחיש את הדרך החלופית אבל השקולה הזו
לחישוב הפעולות
של הפעולות האלה. אפשר להשתמש בכל
דרך שיותר נוחה במצב הנתון.
נקודה אחרונה לגבי
פעולות אוניטריות היא שהרכבות של פעולות
אוניטריות מיוצגות על ידי כפל מטריצות
בדיוק כמו בהגדרה ההסתברותית, כלומר, אפשר לחשב את הפעולה של רצף של פעולות אוניטריות
פשוט על ידי כפל
המטריצות ביחד. ומה שמקבלים היא
מטריצה אוניטרית בודדת שמייצגת את הפעולה המשולבת
של רצף הפעולות.
בדיוק כמו שהיה לנו עבור מטריצות סטוכסטיות, המטריצות האוניטריות
סגורות תחת כפל, אז תמיד תקבלו מטריצה אוניטרית
כשמרכיבים פעולות אוניטריות.
צריך לוודא
שכופלים את המטריצות בסדר הנכון.
אבל הדרך שבה זה עובד היא בדיוק כמו שהיה עבור
פעולות סטוכסטיות שבה המטריצה של הפעולה
הראשונה שמבצעים
תמיד תופיע בצד הימני
של מכפלת המטריצות, והאחרונה תופיע
בצד השמאלי.
אז בדיוק כמו קודם, הסדר מתהפך במובן שמרכיבים מימין לשמאל ולא משמאל לימין.
הנה דוגמה מעניינת שמובילה לפעולה שנקראת פעולת שורש של NOT.
נניח שקודם
מפעילים פעולת Hadamard ואחריה פעולת S, ואחריה פעולת Hadamard נוספת.
הפעולה המשולבת של
שלוש הפעולות האלה מתוארת על ידי המכפלה הזו.
הנה פעולת Hadamard הראשונה, הנה פעולת S, והנה פעולת Hadamard השנייה.
אם מבצעים את כפל המטריצות, שלא מוצג כאן במפורש, אבל אפשר לעשות את זה
בעצמכם אם תרצו,
התוצאה היא המטריצה הזו כאן. היא מטריצה אוניטרית, ואפשר לבדוק את זה ישירות
או לסמוך על העובדה שהמטריצות האוניטריות
סגורות תחת כפל.
היא חייבת להיות אוניטרית כי שלוש המטריצות האלה אוניטריות כפי שכבר ראינו.
אין לנו וקטור מצב
קוונטי ספציפי בראש כאן.
אפשר לדמיין ביצוע
של רצף הפעולות הזה על כל וקטור מצב קוונטי, והמטריצה הזו מתארת את הפעולה.
הסיבה שהפעולה המשולבת הזו, כלומר זו שמתוארת
על ידי המטריצה הזו כאן נקראת פעולת שורש של NOT,
היא שעל ידי ביצוע שלה
פעמיים, מקבלים פעולת NOT, או במילים אחרות,
סיגמא x או פעולת X.
ביצוע הפעולה
פעמיים מיוצג על ידי העלאת המטריצה בריבוע או
כפל שלה בעצמה.
ואם עושים את זה, רואים שהתוצאה
היא מטריצת Pauli x.
וזה סוג של מוזר, וזה נותן לכם רק רמז שאפשר לעשות כמה דברים מעניינים עם מידע קוונטי שלא ניתן לעשות עם
מידע קלאסי.
אין פעולה קלאסית, כלומר כזו שמיוצגת
על ידי מטריצה סטוכסטית שנותנת לנו פעולת NOT
אם מבצעים אותה פעמיים.
אז זו דוגמה יפה שחושפת שפעולות קוונטיות
מתנהגות בצורה מאוד שונה מפעולות קלאסיות.
וזהו לשיעור אחד. בשיעור הזה, דנו באיך מידע קוונטי עובד עבור מערכות בודדות בבידוד,
ובשיעור הבא, נדבר על איך
מידע קוונטי עובד עבור מערכות מרובות.
תודה שצפיתם. אם יש לכם שאלות, אל תהססו להשאיר אותן ב
תגובות למטה.